Chloe are you okay in there do you need
any help I'm coming in
now this meetings going to be about two
hours are you sure you don't have to go
to the bathroom
yeah I'm sure do you want to just try I
can take you it's not a big deal hey
Chloe remember what we talked about with
the printer how it's really nice to take
turns why don't we let someone else use
it you can come back when they're
finished why don't we go around and talk
about with some of our strengths for
this quarter okay whoa whoa okay why
don't we raise our hands if we want to
speak gonna grab some lunch um you can
get lunch after you've cleaned your desk
up a little bit it'll be so nice to come
back to nice clean dad oh I needed those
Chris Rado here
hold on no more kress
bye bye crust you're kidding language oh
my goodness I am so sorry that she spoke
to you that way it will never happen
again alright guys that about wraps it
up thanks for coming we'll touch back
next week and I'm so proud of you oh my
gosh she worked so hard on this
presentation you rocked it come here
sweetheart did you wash your hands
yeah let me smell you lied to me
timeout timeout I'm so disappointed in
you
I bought your phone charger mmm what's
the magic word abracadabra now here let
me get that for you
okay all right see you tomorrow
oh okay drive safely and get to bed at a
reasonable hour no snacks after 8:00
p.m. I love you